[Music]
I'm not going to say anything about that guy with the 26th unit, but I don't want him to act
arbitrarily in the next operation.
It's over yet
What
hiro 2
Don't make
me push myself too hard It's Darling who said he wants to ride with me, but I'm trying to do it,
so at least don't let me be a burden during the day I want you to
give it to me on the
demo machine  You tried it once with Darling and it
didn't work If you're okay with me, you won't even interfere
You're going to use Hiro Darling is mine
You might die That's right, if you die That's it  Until
me,
hello
, I don't mind the counter, after all,
give me
human
doh, listen to
you guys
[music]
no second
[applause]